let's see if we can find the limit as x
approaches negative infinity of the
square root of four x to the fourth
minus x
over two x squared plus three and like
always pause this video and see if you
can figure it out
well whenever we're trying to find
limits at either positive or negative
infinity of rational expressions like
this it's useful to look at well what is
the highest degree term in the numerator
or in the denominator or actually in the
numerator and the denominator and then
divide the numerator and the denominator
by that highest degree by x to that
degree because if we do that then we're
going to end up with some constants and
some other things that will go to zero
as we approach positive or negative
infinity and we should be able to find
this limit so what i'm talking about
let's divide the numerator by
1 over
x squared and let's divide the
denominator by 1 over x squared now you
might be saying wait wait i see an x to
the fourth here that's a higher degree
but remember it's under the radical here
so if you want to look at it at a very
high level you're saying okay well x to
the fourth but it's under is you're
going to take the square root of this
entire expression so you can really view
this as a second degree term so the
highest degree is really second degree
so let's divide the numerator and the
denominator by x squared and if we do
that dividing so this is going to be the
same thing as
so this is going to be the limit
the limit as
the limit as x approaches negative
infinity of
so let me just do a little bit of a side
here so if i have
if i have
1 over x squared
let me write it let me 1 over x squared
times the square root of 4 x to the
fourth minus x like we have in the
numerator here
this is equal to this is the same thing
as 1 over
the square root of x to the fourth
times
the square root of 4 x to the fourth
minus x and so this is equal to the
square root of
4 x to the fourth minus x
over x to the fourth which is equal to
the square root of and all i did is i
brought the radical in here this is you
could view this as the square root of
all this divided by the square root of
this which is equal to just using our
exponent rules the square root of 4x to
the fourth minus x over x to the fourth
and then this is the same thing as 4
minus x over x to the fourth is 1 over x
to the third
so this numerator is going to be
the numerator is going to be the square
root of
4 minus 1
x to the third power
and then the denominator
is going to be equal to well you divide
2x squared by
x squared you're just going to be left
with 2
and then 3 divided by x squared is going
to be 3 over
x squared
now let's think about the limit as we
approach negative infinity as we
approach negative infinity
this is going to approach 0 1 divided by
things that are becoming more and more
and more and more and more negative
their magnitude is getting larger so
this is going to approach 0.
this over here is also going to be is
this thing is also going to be
approaching 0 we're dividing by larger
and larger and larger values and so what
this is going to result in is the square
root of 4 the principle root of 4
over
2 which is the same thing as 2 over 2
which is equal
to one and we are done